avez vous déjà entendu dire que dans
notre société aujourd'hui le vote
n'avait plus d'un
acte la dernière fois que vous êtes
allés voter vous êtes allé dans votre
bureau de vote vous avez glisser votre
bulletin dans l'urne
est ce que vous vous êtes demandé si
votre bulletin avait encore de
l'importance en france depuis vingt ans
on observe une augmentation de
l'abstention à chaque scrutin qu'ils
soient locales nationales ou même
européen l'exemple le plus criant sont
les élections européennes qui sont
vraiment importantes mais qui ne
parviennent même pas à réunir 50 % des
électeurs alors des sondeurs sont allés
voir les abstentionnistes et leur en
demander pourquoi il ne se déplaçait
plus pour aller voter
les raisons sont souvent similaires
ça ne va rien changer mon vote n'aura
aucun impact
les candidats je les connais pas où je
me sens pas représenté
mais même chez les électeurs on entend
beaucoup de vent beaucoup de personnes
qui disent qu'il vote par défaut qu'ils
votent contre quelqu'un qui vote parce
qu'ils sont obligés d'aller voter parce
que c'est un droit est aussi un devoir
et qu'on s'est battu pour pouvoir aller
voter à partir de ce constat je suis
venu vous parler d'une technologie qui
est qui va potentiellement révolutionner
le vote dans nos sociétés actuelles
aujourd'hui chaque pays est caractérisé
par son système de gouvernance
c'est-à-dire que chaque pays a une façon
particulière de décider des règles qui
vont régir la société alors en fonction
des pays ça change beaucoup et on n'est
pas ici pour juger des systèmes de
gouvernance qui existent mais ils ont
tous un point en commun c'est la
centralisation du processus de
gouvernance alors imaginer une société
où voter ce ne serait pas voter pour des
représentants où voter pour des
compromis mais voter pour des décisions
concrètes des aspects qui nous touchent
réellement alors ça paraît un peu
utopique dit comme ça parce
si c'était possible pourquoi aucune
société du monde actuel ne fait pas déjà
ce la meilleure vous parlez d'une
technologie qui peut rendre cette idée
possible et cette technologie c'est là
blocs chain alors là bloqué vous en avez
sûrement déjà entendu parler d'une
manière plus ou moins abstraite sans
vraiment comprendre ce que c'était alors
je vais pas vous faire une explication
détaillée technique de la blood chaîne
mais je vais essayer de vous expliquer
ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui et de quoi
il s'agit alors là blocs chaîne c'est
simple c'est un réseau d'ordinateurs qui
va partager le même registre
d'information en temps réel de manière
inaltérable transparente et sans organe
central de contrôle
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas de direction
de la blog chaîne il n'ya pas président
de l'agglo chaîne
si on doit prendre une décision sur la
blogo chaîne il faut que une majorité
des ordinateurs qui composent la blog
chaîne soit d'accord alors vous
connaissez certainement quelques
applications de la blocs chaîne la plus
connue aujourd'hui étant la crypto
monnaie crypto monnaie le bitcoin
aujourd'hui le réseau bitcoin vous
permet d'échanger de la monnaie
d'échangé de la valeur d'une personne à
une autre sans organe central de
contrôle c'est-à-dire sans banques sans
intermédiaires de paiement
vous pouvez donc disposer entièrement de
vaud fond vous êtes le seul propriétaire
de ces fonds est donc une banque ou un
organisme gouvernemental ne peut pas
venir vous prélevez des bitcoins une
autre application de la blocs chaîne qui
est aussi très puissante
c'est les contres intelligent on appelle
ça des smart contracte en anglais est
alors des contrats intelligent c'est
assez simple c'est du code mais c'est
une suite d'instructions finalement qui
va être exécuté sur la blogo chaîne donc
sur chacun des ordinateurs de la blood
chaîne un exemple qui existent
aujourd'hui qui est assez simple c'est
l'assurance automatique c'est à dire que
si vous voulez prendre un vol demain
vous voulez aller à new york et je
voulais être remboursés au cas où votre
vol est en retard ou au vote faute et
est annulé vous allez souscrire un
contrat d'assurance sur la blogo chaîne
et au moment où votre avion atterrit ou
au moment où votre avion est annulé
l'information remonte de sources
concordantes et indépendante est vous
êtes automatiquement remboursés mais la
dernière application dont je vous
parlais ce sont les organisations
décentralisées autonome on appelle ça
des dégâts ou en anglais alors une
organisation décentralisée autonome
qu'est ce que c'est pas ça repose sur
ces contrats intelligent et c'est
surtout l'exact opposé des modèles de
gouvernance actuelle vous ai parlé de
centralisation est bien une des ao c'est
la décentralisation totale du processus
de décision
c'est à dire que demain que ce soit dans
votre club de sport dans votre
association dans votre arrondissement
dans votre quartier vous pourriez voter
sur des décisions qui vous impact vous
et votre communauté
or chez kia beaucoup de parisiens dans
la salle qui prennent sûrement les
transports en commun pour aller soit sur
leur lieu de travail ou à paris
descartes justement et je pense que
alors je suis un fier usagers de la
ligne 13 et je pense que beaucoup de
gens prennent du des lignes de métro qui
sont saturés le matin et c'est assez
frustrant en plus de ne pas être
vraiment très agréable c'est assez
frustrant parce que à chaque fois on
arrive dans une station qui est bon d un
métro qui est bondé on va encore arriver
en retard parce que le conducteur va
nous dire désolé régulation du trafic
falloir attendre 5 minutes et je pense
qu'il ya une frustration qui se crée
chez les usagers de la ratp et des
transports en commun parisiens et
pourquoi pas créer une des aot donc une
organisation décentralisée autonome pour
gérer les transports en commun parisiens
c'est à dire proposer à l'ensemble des
usagers de voter sur l'organisation des
lignes ou sur des améliorations du
réseau en priorité sur d'autres alors
vous pouvez me dire aujourd'hui les gens
qui prennent des décisions sont des
experts des gens c'est des petits
groupes de personnes
mais ils ont les compétences pour
prendre ses décisions ah ça je pose deux
choses les organisations décentralisées
autonome prévoit ce genre de cas si moi
je prends la ligne 13 je vais pas aller
voter pour les décisions qui vont
affecter la ligne 14
mais j'ai forcément un collègue qui
prend la ligne 14 tous les matins et je
vais donc lui déléguer mon droit de vote
sur cette décision particulière et lui
pour un délégué son droit de vote sur la
ligne 13 est aussi les décisionnaires
aujourd'hui son hymne au riz terre et
possède toute l'information
si on prend des décisions de manière
décentralisée au 20e rang de
l'information qui sert à prendre cette
décision complètement transparente les
avantages finalement de ces
organisations décentralisées cedeao
ils sont assez évidents et ils sont
assez simple on va ré impliquer
l'ensemble des citoyens au sein de leur
communauté
on va bénéficier de l'intelligence
collective car tout le monde a une
expérience
un avis qui compte enfin on va faire ça
en toute transparence
on va répondre aussi un problème très
simple les enjeux personnels
aujourd'hui les décisionnaires sont
minoritaires et doivent prendre des
décisions qui affectent des millions de
personnes ils peuvent être tentés de
prendre des décisions qui vont leur
bénéficier avant de bénéficier au plus
grand nombre
si on prend une décision tous ensemble
elle devrait bénéficier au plus grand
nombre et pas uniquement à ceux qui
prennent la décision
enfin un dernier avantage et il est
taillé une des aot donc une organisation
décentralisée autonome c'est possible
dès maintenant
il vous suffit d'un contrat intelligente
d'un site internet
rien qui change vraiment de l'ordinaire
tout le monde a des compétences utiles
nous devons bénéficier l'intelligence et
de la vie de chacun pour enfin prendre
des décisions plus juste plus forte
mieux comprises et ré impliquer
l'ensemble des acteurs d'une communauté
au sein de celle ci
alors au début de ce talk je vous ai
parlé d'une société où tout le monde
pourrait faire entendre sa voix alors
après ce que je viens de vous dire une
société où tout le monde peut faire
entendre sa voix cécile topic que ça je
remercie
[Applaudissements]